hey guys i'm jess and this might be the
last time you see me looking like this
because Australia has a four-day easter
long weekend which means cheap chocolate
hot cross buns and most severe lack of
self-control us to use first up a
massive update for Ghost Recon wildlands
is out now which is great because I know
for a fact my dad is still playing it hi
that's a few of the things you guys and
my dad will be able to check out in the
new patch include a set of weekly
challenges for solo or co-op play
wherein you can earn up to three in-game
rewards a week the three-point Oh update
also changes some of the dialogue and
radio chatter and fixes an issue where
players XP bars were getting stuck you
can check out the massive patch notes
list in our story on gamespot if you're
on pc wondering where your giant
wildlands patch is yours is arriving on
april 14 so hang in there in other
exciting wild landing news the game's
first expansion knocker road will be out
on April 18 if you've got the $40 season
pass or you can grab it on its own for
15 bucks on April 25 in narco road
you'll be infiltrating gangs and
exploiting the under bosses led by the
ringleader el invisible I'm sure that's
not how you say it right anyway there's
new missions mission types outfits
weapons and vehicles to keep you busy
next up images of the project's scope
your dev kit have arrived yes we finally
get an idea of what the mythical
super-powered box might look like thanks
to these gamasutra published pics quick
note here as this is a deaf kid it may
not look exactly like what you'll end up
with in your living room Xbox boss Phil
Spencer told gamasutra that project
Scorpio will directly portmap the Xbox
one he explained you literally plug
power in a plug HDMI in it's all exactly
the same Spencer went on to state that
Microsoft will support via on Scorpio
but they're not ready to reveal plans
for a headset saying I think we're on
like a decade long journey with VR and
we're still right at the beginning so
I've hesitated to say let's lock on one
piece of hardware on our console and say
this is it because from a hardware
standpoint I think you can kind of do
that though I still think we're early
from an experience standpoint I don't
think we've seen the things that we need
to really have the I'll freak out
finally the internet is still the
internet today and no scheduled premiere
dates are sacred as the first trailer
for star wars battlefront 2 has leaked
it looks like EA are ensuring
battlefront two single player campaign
is front and center as the trailer kicks
off with a female soldiers narration of
the untold soldier's story there is of
course shots of multiplayer angles as
well and as we hoped adore front two
will represent all errors of Star Wars
so look forward to watching Darth Maul
Yoda array and kylo Ren check it out if
you're sick of your crummy speeder bike
there's also a new way to get around
TomTom's you know if you can put up with
the smell if you decide to preorder
you'll also get access to something
called Star Wars the last Jedi Heroes
which is likely related to the last Jedi
film which is due out in December
today's trailer also confirmed that
battlefront 2 is headed to ps4 in
addition to what we expect is an xbox
one and pc release so enjoy that one
sony dance that's everything I've got
for you today so do let me know what you
thought of today's stories down in that
comment section that the US will be
taking care of you for the rest of the
week but I'll see you again next week